battlefield 5 update an important update
for t-series but most importantly of all
puddles
[Music]
good evening I'm poppy Harlow the most
news person in the news our first story
comes from battlefield 5 this is an
update from last week
apparently battlefield 5 had really bad
amount of pre-orders lacking 85 percent
behind call of duty ah sucks some people
a bunch of idiots I'm not supposed to
add my opinion but said this was because
red and redemption is coming out it's
because Call of Duty is coming out
this is oversaturated in October the
true Chad's knew what the reason was
behind this and of course it was because
the chief design officer of Battlefield
said if you don't like our trailer you
are uneducated and then he mysteriously
left the company as you do two months
before I release and I try to explain in
the video why I think people didn't like
the trailer myself included ok they have
done really bad at job and marketing
battlefield so far and I broke that down
but I still saw a lot of people
commenting I don't know it doesn't look
like a bionic arm just like a prosthetic
I called it a bionic arm it's a
prosthetic eye arm I know the difference
I just misspoke ok we don't get our
education about how wars were from games
sure they can do that but it's not their
job it's a school's job I couldn't get
less F about watching battlefield I
wasn't at the war and I wouldn't play to
relive it either yes the trailer just
being a statement is kind of dumb
however people going numb over that just
as dumb so the basically you're calling
me dumb for saying this trailer is dumb
anyway it seemed like so many people
didn't understand what I was talking
about so I will reiterate just to make
this point crystal-clear okay this is
important stop okay I'm not even gonna
pretend that the battlefield 5 trailer
it's not the most important thing in the
entire universe you have to understand
companies aren't mortal beings okay they
will say and do whatever that will bring
them more sales they don't think like
human beings because they're not humans
the problem I have and a lot of people
have with the trailer is not the fact
that there's a woman in it people aren't
going there's a woman no one cares
okay and to be 100% clear I don't have a
problem with women in power in fact I
encourage it okay you want to do that
great good for you but when you're
simulating a war okay they know that
they have to work within a certain
framework okay if they didn't people
would get pissed off and that's what
happened here yes you can say oh well
there were no flamethrowers in the
Battle of Shiva COBOL and no one cares
about that yes you're talking about
objects here we're talking about people
we're talking about human beings we're
talking about history
if battlefield 5 said they're doing a
world war game where sweets are fighting
Nazis in the trenches people would
comment about it in the same way saying
well that didn't really happen did it
and then their response would be oh well
actually 8,000 Swedish people did fight
in the war so checkmate it's like that's
not the point
yes there were women in World War two
but it's not a plausible scenario so if
you want to make the statement or having
a woman in power as the cover of the
game and in the trailer as the main
focus I think it's great it's annoying
that I have to call it a statement but
it's a statement because it's done so
painfully obviously and so poorly if you
wanted to put a female soldier on the
cover why not use something that was
actually I don't know possible okay let
me just acknowledge good intention
terrible execution that's what this is
now apparently a delayed the release of
battlefield until November I think it's
probably a good move
be honest this did cost the stocks of EI
to drop a lot and I'm gonna keep
developing the story and see how it goes
because it's a it's interesting to me
PewDiePie my favourite YouTube channel
I'm not supposed to give my opinion I'm
just popping harlow but my favourite
YouTube channel is being overtaken by
this channel T series you probably heard
about this already but later this year
PewDiePie will no longer be the biggest
channel on YouTube it will be overrun by
the channel T series now Peter PI
bravely challenged T series to a fight
to the death and they have yet to
respond to his request what a bunch of
cowards
PewDiePie has gathered a lot of support
by mr. beast for example Liam lush we
don't stand a chance against the
population of India sometimes is not
about who's going to win it's about
being on the right side of history the
all inclusive channel or the Indians huh
war war is coming
tcha be aware now this was covered by of
course the verge the verge and the
polygon same company it's the same
company owned by bollocks interesting
they're the only ones covering this now
okay right let it be clear I don't care
ok I know that's a false statement
because if I say I don't care I am
saying I care enough to say that I care
and then just go on and it doesn't make
any sense I know the thing is I have
expressed that I don't want to be the
number one channel on YouTube for a long
time okay I would prefer if someone else
passes me if T if T series was an actual
individual and not a company I would
gladly congratulate them on become a
number one it genuinely doesn't bother
me there are are already channels bigger
than me but no one's talking about that
you have music gaming sports and YouTube
movies I'm technically the fifth biggest
YouTube now of course polygons and they
always know how to grind my gears right
so instead of talking about this I
wanted to bring up the point that
bring up in this article where polygon
brings up this video from mat pad which
says ironically what helped children
become the king of YouTube as explained
by Matt Patrick and video channel bear
managed to reach audiences in countries
like Sweden Italy France France okay and
the UK while also building up a fan base
in United States and I've heard this
argument so many times it's just one of
those things that people keep saying and
then it's so it suddenly takes on its
truth on its own because Matt did this
video which is a really good video I
still hate it and I think he should
delete it because he made this
speculation but why this let's play
channel there's thousands out there well
there's one other reason the algorithm
loves PewDiePie
he's international you see YouTube
promotes channels locally if you live in
California your videos will be served up
in California more frequently than in
other areas of the US and if you live in
the US your videos will stay in the US
until you gather enough views from other
countries to merit them sharing your
stuff there PewDiePie has a unique
advantage over most other channels
because YouTube considers his channel
Swedish since he started it when he was
living in Sweden makes sense since then
he's moved meaning that he lives and
uploads from Italy but he also speaks
English so since YouTube promotes
locally he was able to gather a strong
Swedish following in a market where
there was less competition but now that
he uploads from Italy he gets promoted
there and since YouTube is most heavily
used in english-speaking nations he had
a much easier time crossing into the US
and UK than a channel from here would
have doing the reverse ok Matt you had
no idea where you talked to mine this is
such a dumb video and I hate I'd like it
if you want to piss me off just say oh
well pity pie he just grew because he
moved countries the reason this annoys
me especially is because it's the
complete opposite when I started off
doing YouTube there was a lot of ways to
poke through the system there was a lot
of ways you can deliberately do to make
your channel grow
that was technically not allowed but
YouTube didn't really stop anyone from
doing it one of those things would be
that you can set your channel country in
your setting you can set your country to
anything and YouTube will acknowledge
your channel as that it was in
location-based it was purely based on
the settings and back in 2013 the front
page of YouTube was a big part of
growing your channel
it was probably how you gather the most
subscribers if you got on the front page
of YouTube that was a massive deal and
yes each front page on each country was
different so a Swedish so Sweden did
have their own front page just like
America has their own front page just
like there was also a worldwide front
page so what people did was they would
set their channel as Swedish even though
there were American so the front page of
Sweden was nothing but American channels
abusing the system so they would get
views from Sweden when they weren't even
from Sweden while people who were
Swedish didn't grow from it
it annoys me because I was so frustrated
by a by this back in 2013 I kind of
pride myself i that i've never abused
youtube system to grow my channel it's
one of those things where i've seen
while growing my own channel a lot of
other people do and benefiting from it
as well so when people make these
statements saying oh he just grow his
channel because you know he moved from
italy to UK to sweet and that gave him
that boosts its it takes away the value
of all the work I put into this channel
working my ass off the last seven years
and yes it pisses me off so this whole
thing couldn't be more false but it's
one of those things I keep being
reiterated as true it despite me
debunking it it's annoying because
people take Matt's speculation as some
form of true it and here it is five
years later being reported that's true I
don't think I deserved 65 million
subscribers I genuinely don't it makes
no sense to me I don't want to be the
biggest channel like I said I don't care
I don't care I just want to be making
videos do my own thing everything else
is just annoying
dealing with this stuff is
it's kind of fun too okay but it's
annoying none of this makes any sense to
me like why my channel got so big it
doesn't make sense to me either I have
no idea I was at least popular guy in
school I don't understand it still I
still think I'm really there's nothing
special about my content so I understand
that people want a reason for it
another thing that's annoying about this
article is that or leaves in the verge
if you ever want to control a narrative
if you ever wanted something to seem a
certain way all you gotta do is just
hand select a few comments look at this
you can't just hand pick comments I
don't know why they keep doing it well I
know why
brofist army where are you you dare
challenge the king Alexa delete this
channel war is coming
prepare yourself t-series no one asked
you TV series videos I reason been
mostly overrun by swarms of PewDiePie
related comments summing which encourage
people to download and report channels
uploads so they trying to make it seem
like y'all are it's it's all a bunch of
nine-year-olds which it is by the way
spamming this poor channel this poor
channel okay I think I think the video
that gets 15 million musing two days
will be okay I think they will survive
t-series accept my challenge to do that
until then the swarm of nine-year-olds
will keep coming after you and the verge
and anyone that dare challenge us that's
right I pledge my allegiance to
PewDiePie sorry we're out of time I'm
poppy Harlow
thank you for smashing like on this
video it supports this channel along
with hitting to sponsor fun oh you guys
have a good time I soon and I'll see you
guys next week I'm poppy Harlow
[Music]